foreign
is in Atlanta hi Courtney welcome to the
Ramsay show
hey Dave thanks for taking my
car sure what's up
okay so I have fallen into the student
loan conundrum I all of my debt is in
student loans I'm 30 years old I have
about 300 000 in student loans
and I am engaged have been for the past
three years because we are scared to get
married we just because of the debt we
are nervous to buy a home we are
currently renting and we want to get
free we are completely new to you and
your show and your plan
um so we just want to go I understand
why you're scared with three hundred
thousand dollars in student loan debt
why
does getting why does that affect
getting married
um it doesn't I guess I did you told me
you've been waiting three freaking years
all right
um so I guess we neither one of us just
want to go to the courthouse and get
married but where you want to be able to
pay for something nicer is what you're
saying right but are you a doctor or a
lawyer
um I'm actually a pharmacist what are
you earning 100 and a half
um actually it's more like
122 maybe yeah okay does that feel low
it's a little it's a little low but
you're starting you're just you just got
out so
um how long you've been out of school
um for the past three years okay all
right what's his situation I got an
undergrad degree before I actually went
into school
what does he make
um he makes UH 60
and then he also gets uh bonuses does he
have a bunch of that too
he actually he actually has no debt
um and
he has very minimum
though we actually did seek out you know
mortgage pre-approval and we got it but
it was basically yeah you don't you
don't you don't need to buy a house
you're broke so let me tell you let me
tell you a story where we're at let me
tell you a story my husband and I had
280 000 of student loans a little less
than you but if you add our credit cards
in we're you know call it 300. yeah no
credit cards for us my point is your
income is a lot better than ours was
back then at least to start and for the
you guys it doesn't matter like Dave
said getting married is not the issue
matter of fact go ahead and get married
work on this thing together and go
through it together and you're just
gonna have to walk through these steps
and commit to the fact that we've got
this debt here for a couple of years
we're living on nothing to get this paid
off luckily you guys got a good shovel
good shovel I'm sorry you got a good
income and that's it it's just the
student loans right now Courtney you
feel you feel stuck
don't you
I really do and you feel a little bit
ashamed to marry him
and attack and hand him 300K
yeah like you're going this is pretty
serious Dowry here yeah
um
that's an old word but yeah
um you know what I'm saying yeah it's um
so it is messing up not getting married
but it's messing up your view of
yourself and your relationships
difficult
to have one
one um you don't need to have one bank
account until you're married
correct yes let me let me project a
future for you that you haven't seen
let's let's run some numbers for a
second
okay
go get married this weekend
don't just just ride with me on my
little trip here okay
just for a second it sounds absurd but
you've been dating for three years
you've been engaged forever
um we'll celebrate in other ways later
uh now
if I calculated correctly you make 122
he makes 60. that's 182. he has no debt
we have now one house to support one set
of rent one set of heat and air one set
of electricity one set of water one set
of things in the refrigerator
you're with me right so your living
costs go down approximately
I also have a car payment what do you
owe on your car
20. okay I'll put that in the story too
okay no no okay so you make 122 he makes
60. and he has bonuses on top of that
what do you think you'll really make in
the coming 12 months including his
bonuses
um
probably maybe 170 with the I mean maybe
70 with the bonus okay and and I know
this about you you may not but you can
pick up Pharmacy Duty in the ER at the
local hospital on the weekends and you
can make another 25 or 30 if you will
put in a whole bunch more hours than
you're putting in as a temporary measure
okay and so now I'm at 155 and 70. so I
think I'm doing two and a quarter now
anybody with me here
I got three hundred thousand dollars in
student loan debt and I'm going to take
my two and a quarter and I'm going to
live on 50. that leaves me 175 minus
taxes to put on the 300 you're debt free
in two years
just by picking up extra hours picking
up extra hours living together married
and and spending no money you're not
eating out you're not going on vacation
and you're sure as crud not buying a
house we might be selling your car
right to get a cheaper car but we the
goal here is to get free because
otherwise we're stuck we want to get
free so we can buy a house and live a
great life together and build wealth and
have kids and have kids and be generous
but right now you can't see that because
you've got Mount Everest stuck between
you and hope
right and I just took Mount Everest
apart with a pickaxe in two years
I did that
right but I'm telling you
you're gonna you're you're it's gonna be
a really hard two years
because all the little luxuries you're
accustomed to nanya none them you get
nothing don't you dare see the inside of
a restaurant unless you're working there
yeah so tuna fish and Dale bread
I agree yes
um so I guess the biggest thing was I
did hear several several of your advices
to other people just being like don't
rely on Public service loan forgiveness
do it yourself it just got you out of
debt in two years why would you even
bring that up right
well because I guess my fiance sees it
as a way out it's not a way 10-year lie
you know what percentage of the public
loans perfect service loans forgiveness
actually get forgiven less than two
percent 98 gets screwed by this plan
right think about the way you're feeling
right now do you want to feel that for
the next 10 years waiting on waiting on
something that likely won't happen the
reason he wants you to plug into that he
doesn't think there's another way but
you guys make a lot of money together
you sure do and you can make even more
and spend none of it and throw it all at
the student loans and kill that sucker
150 a year for two years out of two and
a quarter and you're free you're going
to be done in two years it took my
husband and I seven and a half
put that in perspective and we rented
the whole time so and you let that make
you and we had well that was after the
fact I know but for you two and after
seven years was it yeah it was after the
senator we waited we rented for here's
the stats we rented for 10 years and
waited for 11 years to have kids wow yep
because it was doing to her what you
thought it was doing to you before this
phone call right now I might be off by a
year
whoopee and nine three years whoopee I
might be off by another year you might
be might do it in a year and a half
because you guys just go bananas and
your husband goes hey game on I'm
working 24 7. we're getting done get
married this weekend and kill this dead
girl do it
well I appreciate your advice I feel
like she's not gonna do it
do it please everybody in America just
heard that you are not thank you for
your advice thank you for calling
Courtney
please do it please prove us wrong
oh hey if you don't do it after this you
know whose fault it is Courtney yours
because we have done our job thank you
for calling kiddo